true to Fumito away does work on eco and
Shadow of the Colossus The Last Guardian
is a fascinating game that portrays a
heartfelt relationship between two
unlikely cohorts a nameless boy and a
giant creature named Treecko who
developed mutual trust communication and
compassion against seemingly impossible
odds their tale is a shining example of
storytelling through subtle cues and
shared experiences the occasional
annoyances that come from trying to
force two members of different species
to cooperate is part and parcel of their
realistic partnership for better and for
worse what an unshakable final act melts
these grievances away leaving you
emotionally invested in the outcome of
Treecko and the boys incredible journey
Oh does I'm a Kakuna RIA Tania it begins
when we find them mysteriously
imprisoned in a dank cave though the
cause of their plight remains a mystery
until the end the need to escape is
immediately understood the environment
rather than guards stand in your way at
the start you only have direct control
over the boy and while you are free to
move around Treecko is subdued by a
metal collar fractured armor and a pair
of spheres lodged in his back your
continued efforts to relieve his burden
slowly but surely earned treecko's
favour in short order he's free from his
shackles and the two of you begin your
tricky escape Treecko and you are
instrumental to each other's progress
it's easy for you to slip through small
passageways and precisely manipulate
objects to activate doors but only
Treecko can leap dozens of feet into the
air and reach high out-of-the-way places
you need to rely on physical positioning
and vocal commands to direct him and
there are moments that could be
considered traditional combat but you
strive to escape
allowing treecko's animal instincts to
kick in as he willingly crushes enemies
under his feet
success in the Last Guardian typically
comes down to identifying the one object
or passage in an environment that allows
you to move ahead the process of
elimination as you peek around corners
and climb piles of rubble in search of
your next step can be taxing as you move
with palpable inertia knocking into
walls and sliding across dusty stone
floors in the process both products of
convincing animation that other games
rarely employ whether by design or
circumstance the duas initially troubled
communication manifests itself
throughout the first half of your
journey when treecko's involved in
troubleshooting puzzles you must endure
his slow reaction times and decipher his
body language during your investigation
a process that will test your patience
given the game's world dense as it is
with intrusive outcrops and heavily
ornamented buildings but Treecko is an
impressive animal to behold with the
mannerisms of a house cat as he rests or
navigates complex environments and the
temperament of a lion during occasional
conflicts with magically powered
sentinels he swats and sniffs
curiosity's sometimes as a hint and
other times because he's simply
distracted when he's enraged the only
way to calm him is through the solace of
petting and coos when you look into
treecko's eyes as you slink out of reach
to pull a lever or when he senses
something frightening you don't see the
artifice that defines most video game
characters you see an honest portrayal
as cliche as it sounds Treecko feels
like a living and breathing animal and
you feel real concerned when you test
the limits of the environment under his
heft he is a brave beast that pulls off
unthinkable stunts feats that are
equally impressive and harrowing for
their inherent danger you often come
along for the ride
clinging to his plumage as he leaps high
above the ground obscured by billowing
fog his appearance is nuanced enriched
with hair and feathers that move with
the wind and jostle as you climb around
his body The Last Guardian is for the
most part a totally convincing
experience that draws you into the
mindset of Treecko and the boy however
there are times when you're reminded
that they do in fact inhabit a game from
beginning to end without an option to
disable it the HUD shows you button
prompts when you're in front of an
interactive object and despite handling
numerous impressive scenes without a
hitch there are rare events with obvious
framerate issues these occurrences by no
means dominate the game far from it but
they make you consider the technological
lattice holding the world together when
your intention should be focused on the
events at hand but beyond these moments
the last Guardians numerous delays and
shift a PlayStation 4 have obviously
paid off your journey is dominated by
awe-inspiring architecture and natural
wonder as you weave in and out of caves
and ruins you're treated to wide views
of towers and bridges that you may never
visit but they live on in your
imagination as you piece together the
story and the world around you
when you reach the end your affection
for Treecko and sympathy for both
characters blossoms The Last Guardian is
a powerful and moving experience for the
ways it makes you care about its
characters masterfully executed
personalities and expressions the
creature is the undeniable star of the
show exhibiting believable physicality
and emotional range but the boy is a
valuable example of how to be patient
and resilient when faced with unforeseen
challenges when the book closes on their
story it's not hard to open it again and
begin anew the bond you worked so hard
to forge remains and after it's all said
and done the emotions Treecko elicits
make you want to give him another chance
to be the patient and effective partner
he truly deserves
[Music]
you
[Music]